my name is Matteo Rica as you can see
I'm a booty smoke I began as a scientist
and then when I was 26 I went living in
the Himalayas where I've been mostly for
last 50 years while not worried about
anything or a quick if there's some
difficulties some hindrance comes in
your way if there's a solution just do
it if there's no solution
there's no point to worry is just
compounding your problem relax and think
of some other things to do which can be
useful and another way where there is a
number of fundamental human qualities
data extremely crucial for flourishing
in life for functioning in the most
optimal way like attention loving
kindness in a freedom inner peace but we
don't see those in the same way that up
no we don't we're not born learning out
of it and bridle can chance or play
badminton but we know that by training
we can get better at that the idea that
oh I will become compassionate or more a
sense of fulfillment and contentment
inside of no better or to deal with my
emotion and twirls just like that
because I always good I want it it's
just saying you know I don't want to
practice the piano but
I really want to play like a dog
distract Jenna slit his at carnagie or
doing a concert in essence you can't
enhance your skill without training and
that takes time no magic bullet so I
remember when I was 20 it really kind of
confused what skills should I training
to make sense in my life and that I'm
sort of happy to be alive I think that's
a very crucial question especially for
young people because they have been sort
of taken through the system you do your
best and sometimes you do it willingly
something less willingly then at some
point you really have to ask yourself
okay but really really matters and
someone let that come at the surface I
remember a phrase of an older Greek poet
Mustafa who said education is not just
filling advanced is lighting a flame so
I think to find that flame and keep
makes sense and it's not always where we
think it may be there will be somewhere
some skill or some area where you really
feel inspired so look for that and then
do what's necessary to achieve that
so basically it stems from this acoustic
cloth may people find happiness on the
cause of it why not why not we sing that
to everyone why would you want to
exclude some because you see if you
think of what happiness really is if you
say may all beings be happy
it doesn't mean may they be happy by
doing terrible things cheating others
bullying lying because that's not
bringing happiness to them and that's
not breaking the pinyons to others when
you say many people be happy and find
the cause of happiness or may people be
compassion may people be free from
suffering that means also free from
anger free from arrogance free from
narcissism
so altruism is really wishing the real
good of people that define the way to
flourish and compassion the simple how
can you have compassion for a dictator
before Bashar al-assad so it doesn't
mean oh you know not so bad after all no
so yes maybe has some good sighs not
that at all or renders its barbaric but
the wish you can do may that be
remaining so I made a change may is
action be prevented without hatred or
you may wish that mainly work so that we
provide the condition in society to
education to care so that these things
don't come up of society so you see it's
not a just wishing good very soft you
just wish
we've got hold of suffering take out
this root
so wherever I go in the world including
New York if I can be of little service
otherwise why should I stay when should
I move I'm perfectly fine my Hermitage
facing the Himalayas so why I come down
to be of service otherwise waste of time